Hey Youtubers it's Charlie so everyone's freaking
out Obi-Wan Kenobi Darth Maul rematch may
be a Luke Skywalker teaser so let's break
it down even though Rogue one is already out
just because the hype for star wars episode
8 is picking I'm going to go ahead and keep
the Star Wars giveaway going it's for IMAX
gift certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything.
So let's do the biggest stuff first.
Number 10 Obi-Wan Kenobi on Star Wars rebels.
If you didn't know like you see them use a
little bit older than he was before in the
message went as Russ hearing the message from
the hall across.
That's from order 66 at the end of episode
three of this like a recording of this version
of Obi-Wan Kenobi much earlier in the timeline.
This takes place in the years before Rogue
one, that they didn't say exactly how many
years, but it's probably just a couple like
very close to when Rogue one happens, but
if there was any question Rogue one happens
after this and then episode four.
So that's the order, but Obi-Wan Kenobi, you're
in the wrong place bro in its Darth Maul.
So Darth Maul versus Obi-Wan Kenobi.
This can be so awesome.
But number nine.
I would be willing to bet that this is the
season when they finally end Darth Maul because
we know as of the original trilogy he's not
alive anymore so it some point he will meet
his and during the series but because of the
arc that Ezra is on Ezra is probably going
to be the one to kill him.
I don't do the Obi-Wan Kenobi we kill them,
but we got a hard-core rematch on our hands.
Remember number eight the last time they faced
off Obi-Wan Kenobi chopped in half and through
them down a shaft and that was the last we
heard of them till he came back during clone
wars with the help of some sick technology
in the night.
Sisters must.
So if you rewatch the Star Wars movies recently
and you want to go for like episode three
to now the Darth Maul clone wars episodes
explain how he came back in, where he came
to now but they're actually much older now.
So it's like old Darth Maul versus old Obi-Wan
Kenobi.
So it's very much in the tone of that Obi-Wan
Kenobi versus Darth Vader seen on the death
Star like two old people who haven't seen
each other in a long time have a lot of history
together but of is the Darth Maul's history
with Obi-Wan Kenobi is all bad he killed his
master quae gun.
So is not like they used to be friends or
used to be his paddle water something like
that number eight though the dark saber.
So if you're not current on Star Wars rebels
the dark saber is another call back to the
clone wars he was wielded by Manda Lori in
general the tried to seize power when a little
bit nuts Obi-Wan Kenobi fought him Fort he
spent a lot of time on Mandalore helping out
Satine who was the Duchess of Mandalore remember
that was like the big romance of Obi-Wan Kenobi,
there's a lot of theories that rate from the
new trilogy might be his granddaughter through
sateen but just you.
All speculation at this point, so wide open
to theory crafting, but the dark saber is
an ancient weapon as you can see, it's kind
of like a light saber, but Sabine is using
it to unite the Mandalorians who have been
fractured.
So if she can wield it successfully and hold
it and you can see that they're trying to
get them to join the rebellion.
So this all comes back around to Rogue one
stuff number seven as of Rogue one, when the
rebel fleet meets the imperials at scarif,
it's basically all of the mon calamari and
you can see some inklings of a wings X wings
but they haven't quite got to that point as
of right now in rebels.
So you're slowly sing a bunch of rebel cells
come together to form what is the rebel alliance
as you can see number six Admiral Thrawn feels
like he has it all in hand.
He's the master tactician he has that really
bad ass training scene where he just laying
into all those battle droid just going crazy
just presenting him is this total bad ass
that knows way more about the rebels in the
rebels know about themselves like he knows
them better than they know themselves and
he has the full resources of the empire at
his disposal, so number five the desert planet.
This looks a lot like Jed hop from Rogue one
and because we have Saw Guerrera that means
that we might be seeing a lot of the same
stuff that we saw during Rogue one, they're
doing a lot of Rogue one characters.
They even mentioned number four fulcrum in
casting and/or from Rogue one was confirmed
to be one of the fulcrums but he could show
up on rebels to if the gonna do Obi-Wan Kenobi
they done Leah they done so many original
trilogy characters.
It would make sense that more Rogue one characters
will come onto speaking of which, right now
the death Star is being constructed number
four now how is it being constructed in secret
without the rebels knowing about it like a
couple seasons of Star Wars rebels we haven't
seen too much of it but the way that the Empire
kept it secret was by compartmentalizing a
lot of its construction operations doing it
in a remote sector of space where they could
control the traffic.
But this is really interesting and kind of
gruesome but that Geonosians who responsible
for designing the death Star were essentially
wiped out like they committed a mass genocide
of their bug race.
So that is a giant bug hunt, just to keep
the death Star secret and if you're wondering
why they didn't tell us that in the movies
it just because they they want to keep a little
bit of that for the expanded material.
But as of right now that you know since no
longer exist anywhere they were completely
eradicated in the way that the Empire tried
to eradicate the Jedi order.
In fact, actually now that I think of it.
This desert planet might actually be Geonosis
because like looking at the episode titles.
It just as ghosts of Gia gnosis so that looks
like where this is so the probably find out
about the genocide then what about Canaan
he's been training with the Bendu practices
both light side and dark side for skills.
He's turning into something of like a super
Jedi.
So in the way that Obi-Wan Kenobi also learn
to become a force ghost.
I wouldn't be surprised if Canaan starts to
learn some of that stuff the season to but
he just becoming more and more powerful even
though he's lost his sight you lose one of
your senses, but everything else gets tightened
like a set number to the big thing I think
that Ezra is going to be the one to kill Darth
Maul and that'll push them even more towards
the dark side.
I can't wait to see how they change the canon
to explain where he shows up during the original
trilogy because he's such a big figure.
Now, there's so much story behind them that
they have a lot of explaining to do.
But number one.
Though is Obi-Wan Kenobi on this desert planet
which seems like tattooing makes me wonder
if will get the teaser for Luke Skywalker
coming on the show eventually.
So just because they bring everybody from
the original trilogy back on the show doesn't
guarantee Luke Skywalker, but I definitely
think it's a possibility because Mark Hamill
does.
So much voice acting for animation that I
totally think he would be down to try and
do a younger version of himself as Luke Skywalker,
but because this is happening before episode
four talking about like 1415-year-old Luke
Skywalker let me know what you guys think
of the trailer and let me know if you think
were gonna see Luke Skywalker on rebels, but
what can happen next is absent.
New flash season three, so that'll be the
next video to post what you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn all
about that Darth Vader scene in Rogue one
and you can click here for all my Rogue one
Easter eggs that you so much watching everybody
thought five I'll see you guys tonight!